[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
bobby's going to lose his place as the
acting king in your pit in your house
jesus
jesus is right good will hunting or
range you played
uh a white chick
a valley girl and you played will
uh
tom
matt damon you were fantastic you're
[ __ ] amazing can't believe this piece
of [ __ ] isn't answering the phone
forward god
i think people are going to be blown
away call bobby
bobby
you think he'll answer yeah
what if it weren't a ring went duh
super offensive
elizabeth banks struggles with a boston
accent
what accent do you think i have
i don't know a normal one really crazy i
think that america is just
like accent free they're not answering
those guys are too good to answer it's
it's brokay
oh tom just called me
what that
okay he's gone oh what a dick yeah yeah
so um
these guys got a lot of nerve calling us
i think
i'll tell you why they're uncomfortable
they can't do it like we can't they
don't know how to go to a new
environment and just explode right
they're over there going what do we do
these guys go to when they're doing it
maybe these guys i have a feeling that
these two yeah navid and the rotund yeah
right did he just call right back he did
santini
brandy
hey hey oh my god look what came out of
my mouth oh my god what the [ __ ] is that
was stuck in my throat the whole [ __ ]
time
oh my god tommy tom uh bobby just hocked
up what looks like a tonsil stone that's
that's no [ __ ] i'm not kidding it's that
the size of like an m m
that's huge it's on your table i know it
was in my throat the whole time listen
what's up rudy just [ __ ] won an oscar
she's got chops she's an actor man she's
an actor
like
we know how dope she is by the way uh
the crew over here is loving us and uh
and they even said to us like this is a
completely different level guys a new
level they said you guys are leveling up
yes so we're like i know
should we dumb it down a bit you know
no no
nikov nikov said slow down a little bit
you guys are crushing way too hard for
the time like he's like usually i'm
gonna go do a movie review to slow it
down yeah let's go slow yeah
yeah yeah hey listen we need to bang
some shows
hey but i feel like rudy's 10 times the
act of obvious i feel like it's going to
cause some problems oh his face just
dropped i love what they're doing his
face just dropped i lowered the trouble
i love it it's not going to affect me
god dude it's not going to no he's
touching his face when he touches his
face it means he's nervous he's nervous
when he touches his face oh my god when
he gets sad he touches his face
why doesn't he ask her for help when he
has auditions and stuff yeah that's why
i'm really funny oh dude you're getting
that tom talking he's touching i saw the
horror
[Laughter]
he's saying pretty racist [ __ ] but just
give him a second
bobby says he wants to poop on the table
oh that sounds like a bobby move oh man
that'd be great it's so fun doing this
it's a really good idea
i'm so glad we switched to you why the
[ __ ] would we do
[Laughter]
pick up your phone navad
jesus
sanitize the mics please
sanitize the mics he said yeah first of
all you guys got corona that's true now
i already had it yep bobby is impervious
to it how's he impervious because you
know they say if you're if your blood
type
his blood type is soy sauce they can't
get it if you have soy sauce blood
yeah he eats birds
oh [ __ ] you might honestly you might you
might be able to get it
that's bert's my 20th and you know my 23
minutes i'll tell you what it says
yeah all right hold on
oh buddy's on my side yeah of course
yeah
he's disappointed that he's on that
you're on his side
bobby's mad right now he's pissed off
that you said that about the acting it's
not that it's
this is all just waste of time oh he
thinks it's a waste of time okay all
right pick up the phone all right okay
love you bye bye tom just called me
let's call tom
real quick
let's just check in with these guys i
hope he doesn't complain
yeah
hey hey man
this is a [ __ ] show
it's so rude
it's so rude what's the problem
everything's a problem the [ __ ] the
chairs goddamn rudy your staff put it up
to the mic you know i come in here dude
i come in here dude right
speak english speak english go ahead oh
that's very funny i come here right and
i say hi to the the
the the the larger guy that works here
yeah whatever the guy the rotund
the circle right and then i come in here
i say hey nevad right right yeah the guy
other guy the jew
right
so nice even though i was 20 minutes
late so nice 30 right 30 minutes late
right what are you doing over there that
woman that in there her name is jules
she's she's my daughter pretty much
they're trying to steal her food they
want to take away food out of her
family's mouth hey i guess what what
bert took one of our own crustables
oh
my god let me talk to jules this is war
dude yeah
that's like the only that's all it's so
bobby
how are they
very kind
[Laughter]
run
run get out of there run all right hi
hi bobby
everything is good
everything is good
oh my goodness do they have a gun to
your hand yeah she's [ __ ] dirty
they're tied up she's tied up do they
have you tied up
okay bye to bobby
hey she's dead
yeah
hey i got to tell you something hung up
on him
[Laughter]
that's our thing we do that to people
it's dumb we hang up on people it's
hacky and dumb we did it last week
[Applause]
oh that was fun hold on let me call
santina
[ __ ] i'm gonna call her [ __ ] aunt
she loves you who i did i did um what's
it called what's his tiger belly yeah
man
hey man
we definitely haven't started yet
because bobby's late but also
i don't want to like talk [ __ ] or like
come off like i'm not appreciative of
this but like yeah
nadav answers the door and i said hey
man great to see you and he goes let's
get this going you get that what he said
to me jesus
jesus enough what is that about dude i
just i i don't get it i don't know if
that's his thing now he's got a lot he's
got a lot of pent up like jay anger
deep within you know he does yeah you
know and i don't know he was like i'm on
break when i said hey will you help me
set this thing up he said i'm on break
and he was in the second room there just
eating nickels he was just killing
nickels that sounds right he does that
because he thinks they're pennies now
let me ask you something uh there's no
way this is [ __ ] real so giuliani's
over here and she's [ __ ] just going
[ __ ] ham on these uncrustables
yeah so you know they're bart's favorite
treat and then i go hey can you throw
him one she goes there's only four and
i'm hungry
the kids gotta eat though but well well
make like make bart do something for it
you know what i mean like i mean
but four i mean what the [ __ ] she weighs
like 80 pounds she can't just eat four
dude we let her eat only on the show
otherwise she goes back in her cage when
she goes back home she doesn't get to
eat until we take it so when we film
she's allowed to snack and then after we
film she goes back in her cage but i
will say this make bart do some
semblance of a competition to get one of
those for her she loves competition okay
i'll do that and let me tell you
something else just before i let you go
here um we were really excited to work
with like a high level producer
and that [ __ ] is not happening over here
no it's not no no it's not is it is it
the mexican kid or the what is the
argentinian or whatever is he there i
don't know where the [ __ ] he's from he
looks like he's from north africa
yeah
he's he's atrocious and is uh is uh
george yeah and he it takes him [ __ ]
30 minutes longer to search for [ __ ]
than it takes native he couldn't even
search quest love he's right here
dude it's terrible i mean [ __ ] rudy
won't share her snacks
um
uh [ __ ] the the fancy bee is he's
just like he's holding his pinky up when
he talks to us like he's real fancy and
then
george is terrible at everything that a
producer would do okay can i just say
this yeah at least we don't have to
drive nine hours to get to the [ __ ]
studio you piece of [ __ ] but your studio
sucks hey this studio is like three
blocks from my house bobby
piece of [ __ ]
all right you owe me [ __ ] gas money
you [ __ ]
i'm sad my dog almost died today you
piece of [ __ ] i have to drive all the
way out of you
i'm sorry you ever [ __ ] talk to me
like that again
all right bye-bye all right bye
jesus guys that went well do you want to
ask any more questions to us
um
do you like bad friends
all right that was a good episode i
think yeah it was a lot thank you for
being a bad friend
[Music]
[Music]